like i would need a moment just to like
not talk to a kid
[Applause]
holy cow i love what a great edit
ever
that back the tank was filthy he like he
was a dirty boy
a lot of loose skin
welcome back to new rock stars this is
wikileaks we are live on location here
outside of star wars celebration 2022
the anaheim convention center i'm eric
glass i'm tommy bechtold and i am all
goofed up on obi-wan kenobi frosted
flakes baby i'm reaching for them look
at these
not a sponsor sponsor they're great or
are they evil he didn't even have to
dance for them he just you sat there
in the hands of a child he planted his
jedi mind inside of theirs and said you
will give me those frogs
of cereal
now when you clicked on this video you
saw me and tommy reacting that's
something we recorded after what we
recorded now but trust us we just saw
obi-wan kenobi episodes one in two we we
were able to get invited to see an
advanced screening with the cast and
crew we get to see everybody thank you
hayden christensen ewan mcgregor deborah
chow moses ingram and rupert friend uh
anyway so we're gonna do a live
recording right here of uh of wikileaks
for you we're gonna break down all your
biggest questions that you had coming
out of obi-wan episode one and two uh
and we're gonna start with the the
ending of that episode uh of episode two
uh a huge moment smash cut tayden
christensen waking up in the back to
take
it seems like it might have just been
obi-wan his old master finally saying
his name after 10 years yeah and he's
like what
the hell's calling me at this hour i'm
in my back
i'm
[Music]
all right so uh but before we talk about
everything that happened in this episode
we want to give our our friends uh at
the epic hero shop a huge shout out
because they have a brand new obi-wan
kenobi inspired shirt uh i believe it
says wanted in auravesh there at the top
the design looks so amazing head on over
to new rockstarsmerch.com
uh and uh and and get yourself one of
those when you do uh you'll have the
added option to write in a custom shout
out that we will uh react to they're
gonna run along the bottom i don't think
people have bought the shirt yet so we
don't have any yet to react to but uh on
wednesday when episode 3 comes out you
better believe we're going to be giving
you some love so make sure
get your hands on one of those shirts
and i'll be getting a shirt and i'll be
giving a shout out to you eric
really i'm going to get a shirt i'm
going to say this one goes out to eric
my uncle tommy my my uh my padawan
my star wars celebration padawan i'm
walking eric through the crowds i have
him on one of those baby leashes it's
great tommy has been uh a godsend
because if not for him i would just run
i would just run right into traffic uh
and i just feel a gentle tug back and
i'm back in daddy's arm you're sick
you're safe here um i wrote some notes
on my phone and we were not allowed to
have our phones out so i did this for
you in fact at one point i was just
writing notes i wasn't recording
anything i would never do that
especially since the episode's going
live yeah like an hour to after the
bootleg wouldn't have too much street
value
i had enough to say sir can you put your
phone away i had that humiliation that i
had to suffer but i needed the notes i
needed the notes we had to have the
notes you didn't realize she was
actually talking to me i was playing
angry birds
right so let's uh break down what
happened in episode one uh episode one
of course we uh opened in order 66 the
moment i saw the course on skyline i was
like oh
god damn it yeah we're gonna have to see
some kids get murdered after we see a
young padawan wearing the stupid bowl
helmet
and doing some tai chi you know there's
some jedi moves isn't even equipped with
a lightsaber to defend themselves yet
right away the 501st storms then tommy
what was your reaction i was like my god
they're going to make us relive this
over
and over we are now the haunted
surviving jedis forced to relive the
most traumatic night of our lives in
every series every single series we're
going to revisit this oh my god it still
gets you every single time i had chills
i love that we get to revisit it the um
so we say in a single take it seems like
uh like so we feel the the trauma of
this in a whole new way um and then we
jump to 10 years later the inquisitors
of the grand inquisitor the uh fifth
brother and the third sister reba are
arriving and tattooing and uh they they
go into this uh shop and there's like i
like how they have intel that there's a
jedi nearby who's helping people out
well there's some robin hood here yeah
we didn't sanction this force usage here
so uh and we we learned that there's
this interesting divide between uh the
grand inquisitor who once he wants to
seemingly convert people to explain his
rationale right then you have the fifth
brother who wants to use the carrot and
then you have riva who wants to use the
stick yeah or in this case use like a
spearhead
like if i just she's totally willing to
use that she doesn't know she's uh going
to get stopped with the force but she
assumes i mean the grand inquisitor i
think he made that side eye over at
benny saffy yeah and i think he knew
well and there were the slashes on the
wall that looked like lightsaber slashes
that's how i
jedi was not as cautious as obi-wan
kenobi and he had used his lightsaber
got it yeah that's i mean the the clues
there that uh just the blocking you know
in this opening scene like you know
cutting to different extras yes i mean i
gotta say background acting is a
thankless job yeah but the extras they
had in that scene all did a wonderful
job of possibly being the jedi as they
were it was like a hitchcock thing of
like who's the murderer in the room is
it the bald masculine like tough serving
guy who totally looked like he at any
moment could just flip up his ball and
start you know totally force pushing
people i mean had i not known that benny
safety like what he looks like he's
gonna be in the show i wouldn't have
thought uh there was like a moment where
he was kind of just like
doing some shifting yeah shifty
expressions um so they he ends up
escaping and then we go to obi-wan we
see him at work he's got a nice gig
chopping up some meat
he's like a sushi chef yeah and he
always he's able to cut a little slice
for himself and seems to just wait till
the guy's not looking and i like this
this droid that they clock out on like
go yeah get out of here
it's like that it's like that uh
that's the droid equivalent of like the
mush at your job that's like every
monday
same day different world living in
paradise another day in paradise
it's like rosie in the jets
and we see all these opportunities where
obi-wan can help people out he doesn't
he uh he doesn't help the guy who gets
punched in the gut all these cats that
could get saved he doesn't save the cat
that was a really smart choice in
episode one uh to do that uh we see that
he has these uh dreams um you know at
night cutting back to all of our prequel
highlight reels give it give us some
knees
yeah with some christensen give us and
it seems like for a moment that's what
they were gonna do he calls out into the
cavern and he goes qui-gon no response
tommy i feel like by the end of this
we're going to get a uh a niece and
quiegon's going to be like stop calling
me i am trying to bang a natalie
portman's ghost
whoa the age gap is not okay i can't i
don't know 40 nissan 70. once you get
over 30 it's fine and that's a bectold
endorsement
so he uh we had this adorable uh moment
with the jawa yeah this drawer who
steals his stuff from him
obi-wan knows it i guess that's our save
the cap yeah yeah right like the fact
that he lets the jawa get away yeah and
he buys the t16 skyhopper toy the same
one presumably that we think luke plays
with yes and a new hope but owen lars
later smashes it throwing it back at him
but i love this little like uh santa
kenobi at night
for young luke uh who who flees his uh
farmer uncle yeah just so he can uh and
i like that moment like he snuck away
from him then jumped up on the side of
the homestead she's like what if i could
fly away from this [ __ ]
i wish i could literally fly this sandy
glue out of here this place sucks
um we get another refusal a call where
obi-wan talks to benny saffie's jedi and
just refuses to help him out and he's
like what happened to you just kind of
voicing all of us like what happened to
this guy i mean we know what happened
heartbreak heartbreak happened
um but it uh then we have
one of my favorite transitions ever we
cut to the cliffs
and i lost my mind because i know what
this geography looks like
we get a nice little fake out again
where the little princess is being
dressed up but it's not leia it's her
fake out she loves that she loves
sending a body double even one that is a
completely different alien species yup i
don't care she's got her little droid
lola she's tree climbing she's spotting
different ships i like how this is kind
of like we get to see how similar she is
with her brother like the fact that her
brother would you know look at different
ships and be able to spot i mean there
was those deleted scenes from uh from a
new hope
he was with bigs and they were he was
able to be like oh those ships like leia
was doing the same thing on the older on
and i love that uh great cast and they
got the girl from bird box yeah great
she's incredible on the show uh wise
beyond her years
but as was you know as was 18 or 19 year
old carrie fisher in a new oath right
totally totally she's not she's only
isn't that crazy this girl's nine years
away
yeah she was the highlight i think of
those two episodes i already said
earlier my name is todd nice to meet you
um so we just i mean there's been so
many wonderful people here uh and you
just got a moment of that uh super nice
people have come to say hello and uh if
you see this video and we're still
around come say hi to us we love meeting
we don't mind it we really don't mind it
and it makes us look cool and honest and
we never are cool the babes
it's
go
palpable emotion here um so we get to uh
hang out with uh the organas basically
on on uh alderaan and it's just so sad
to see this beautiful beautiful kingdom
on alderaan knowing what
is going to happen to it in the future
it just sucks um now jumping ahead here
um
when uh the you know the alderaan
extended family comes into town i like
how bale is even kind of like sick of
them yeah uh like this whole side of the
family so yeah these guys are like
really annoying yeah privileged cousins
yes they're like oh we're not getting uh
we're not eating wagyu
crate tonight we're just getting sirloin
crate is this is this is this rib roast
i only eat white you so uh
she she shuts down her cousin later
sneaks out gets snatched by bandits
bandits including
perfect casting across the board on the
show the cast seems great um also we
were promised a cameo by fleet he is a
main player in two episodes of this show
big deal on the show uh so a bale his
wife put out the call to obi-wan he
again denies about gets someone better
he's he accepts the fact that he's
passed his prime i think i think that
wasn't just him being lazy i think he's
like i'm not the man for the job i'm
gonna get my ass kicked yeah he's like
i don't do i mean he's
it's kind of uh his fight scenes are not
him like john wicking people no his
fight scenes are him getting his ass
kicked as well yeah yeah um so um leia
gets snatched and bale actually makes a
personal visit which is a big deal for a
senator like him to go to a [ __ ]
like tattooing right you know he had to
ride in the opie and his balls are
chasing he's like this is hard
to visit they took my daughter um it's
been that's a different nissan different
but i like how we close out this episode
by obi-wan he told benny sappy's
character barry or your lightsaber and
of course that's what obi-wan did he
buried both his and they're all barry
and lightsaber and i love the symbolism
of that he it's almost like he buried
himself his jedi self and anakin's jedi
and ben rose
like uh like uh like uh what thomas
hayden church did spiderman three
um and then he he leaves the planet
flashing his lightsaber on his side and
then we move on to episode two we go
right to daiyu
uh a beautiful world building here yeah
the design is great amazing futuristic
obviously sorry statement of the century
but like it looks i mean it's kind of
like those macquarie artworks of like
the future towns of the future and like
things like that is
yeah it was uh
it looks cool based on hong kong
apparently orbit everywhere i'm gonna be
breaking all that down in the breakdown
you stay tuned um well we get this
amazing cameo of a clone trooper played
by timora morrison yeah you know
speaking of cameos i completely skipped
over something from episode one
the character who gets her hand chopped
off and tattoos
uh he completely skipped over owen lars
as well telling obi-wan to back yeah um
but and the fact that he did this for
for obi-wan that he was able to uh to to
not come clean yeah uh and he said i
didn't do it for you obviously it seemed
like he did it for his family but i
think he also did it for her i think
there's a little bit of him that knows
that yeah anakin did himself in you know
there's a part of him that's like
because he always kind of disapproved of
anakin's behavior right like he was
never like this is cool right so i think
there yeah there's a little piece of him
that's like i know he did it to himself
a little bit too yeah
well and also like i think he so fears
riva in that moment where he's like even
if i tell her i knew a jedi
she's gonna talk to obi-wan he's gonna
find out why why he's there and it's
going to hurt it's going to come back to
life and i don't want luke to get killed
right and i'm going to get killed and
brews going to get killed right so um
anyway so uh yeah so tommy tell us yes
what you're near well i guess you know i
actually auditioned to be the character
that got their hand cut off and argue
with the inquisitors uh obviously they
went with nearly a body double of mine
so that always stinks middle age woman
red hair i was telling eric uh you know
when you audition as an actor and then
you see the final product of a role that
you didn't get it always feels so much
better when it's the physical opposite
of you when you're like oh there was
never a point where they were like it's
either this giant hairy man or this tiny
little redheaded woman
no i'm sure that was never the
conversation but what an honor to get a
chance to even audition for that show
and hopefully if they make more star
wars which it seems like they might
based on the panels we're at today i'll
get another chance to get in there guys
because nothing would please me more
than to look all of you in the eye
through a camera lens and break down an
episode of star wars content that i was
in can you can you tell us what your
line was like yeah it was that line it
was that line so so they everything is
coded
it's all everything like all the
characters are referred to as like the
general and i was referred to as like a
factory worker and it was like you have
no jurisdiction here like the like the
the empire doesn't control the outer rim
and then and then in the sides it said a
weapon cuts off your hand and that's
when i knew it had to be a lightsaber
and baby let me tell you they might have
seen a little desperation in my eyes in
that audition david because your boy was
hungry for some kenobi role although i
didn't even say it was kenobi it just
said live action disney project i'm
probably giving away trade secrets i
don't care for the new rockstars fans
it's celebration i give it away favreau
says give it all away at celebration i'm
with that you're getting the scoop
that's right so anyway blessed to even
have the opportunity happy for that
red-headed woman i'll see you in kenobi
season four
um so speaking of cameos um tomorrow
morrison showed up as a clone trooper i
don't think it's rex i think it's a
clone trooper and tommy spotted
something in the credits yeah of episode
two
that he he was not on set i think they
mocapped his face and they used his
voice yeah but they had a different
actor because he wasn't even in the a
guest star co-star right that would
normally come at the end where you see
like kumal's name and all the other
actors he was just listed in like a
almost like voice effects where they put
the droids and like the droid actors and
stuff like that we're like bill hader
and um
uh what's his name ben uh
uh the guys who did bb-8 the first time
oh yeah young schwartz and then
how they were kind of credited as like
the vfx voiceover like buried in the
credits kind of like that yeah um uh so
uh obi-wan is able to track down he's
looking for the girl trying not to add
himself as a jedi and find someone who
is pretending to be a jedi played by
jamil i freaking love
nanjiani perfect casting as a con man
yeah grifting people but still doing the
honorable thing of trying to get them
off the world just a little poor doing
it like a like a carnival hustler yeah
magnets strings a guy working with him
on the other end pretending to be jedi
wizard yeah yeah but he was like the
wizard of oz of that world i just like
how susceptible the people die you are
they've never seen automated doors and
shutters
absolutely huh
yeah we have to do everything manually
it's like meanwhile everything is
futuristic people are floating outside
cooking on like old like
x-wing engines that's crazy yeah okay so
obi-wan now goes through like a meth lab
it looks like yeah
and is able to get to where he thinks uh
leia is being kept but it's a trap yeah
of course uh because uh riva sent these
bandits and uh smart moves smart play by
riva just a ballsy one and uh and then
yeah it's able to get to her cell after
beating up some other guys uh and is
gassing flea because flea catches them
and he's able to like throw a smoke
grenade uh and then uh he spiced him
didn't he it was spicy yeah yeah it must
have been drugs right i love that we
finally get to see someone under the
influencers
because we've talked about we've never
actually seen it is that the tv 14 range
oh my god
yeah that's why this one went up on a
notch i think together they're giving
people main lining spice in the next one
it's going to be ma17
we get a tempest flare between the
inquisitors at this point because uh the
grand inquisitor did not want uh riva to
do this but he's not gonna let her take
the glory of this kill uh and wants to
track down everyone himself i like how
the fifth brother at one point we see
him walk towards the camera and then
just like walk away from the camera if
you know they had a sun king just like
walk towards the camera and it's like
ann reverse shot okay walk away uh and
uh and then riva pulls the john wick too
and just activates all the bounty
hunters in here nice cameos in there
that was fun yeah uh and then meanwhile
obi-wan and leia you know lovely banter
between these two so much fun her making
fun of how old he is held his
grandfather maybe he's like what was
that
yeah and
she he she has this moment where he's
like you remind me of someone she's like
was she a jedi i know she was a leader
yeah talking about her mother padme for
a second i'm like it's you talking about
satin oh and that is
padme i'm pretty sure it's been and that
is a great star wars thing where they
play on your reliance and hero worship
of the male characters
like the whole
original trilogy leads up to yoda being
like there is another you know like
or whatever and then you you know like
leia ends up kind of being the one that
like i mean ultimately luke obviously
like you know turns vader back over to
the light side of the forest but still
like in this one it was great like you
thought like oh maybe he's talking about
anakin yeah and then it's like no he's
talking about padme maybe yeah
um so uh riva parkour's around daiyu
until she's able to get find the fire
fight
with uh with obi-wan and the other
bounty hunters um but then uh they're
able to escape um thanks to uh camille
comes back yeah does he breaks good he
breaks good yeah and he even like
stalls her yeah which is so sweet yeah
uh bummer though uh she she force chokes
him but he didn't die he didn't die i'm
surprised she didn't kill him yeah
because you gotta think like to her it's
gonna be insulting but i think that
tells us something about her she has one
singular pursuit and that's to find
obi-wan if it were the grand inquisitor
or the brother i think he would have
killed him just feeling disgusted with
someone who would pretend to be a jedi i
agree um anyway so uh reba is creepy as
all hell yeah
uh they're able to escape but she
reveals to someone obi-wan did not know
that anakin is alive and some great
face acting great crazy they put the
camera right
i have to do to kill someone but it
gives us this nice moment where he
hasn't even thought about like he's
thought about it of course but he
couldn't have even fathomed it he would
still be alive which is we'll talk about
that more in a second they're able to
get away
uh and as uh you know she screams after
him great moment and then as they head
to a new planet mapuzo that's where
we're gonna be headed next uh some
people who can help him out uh which is
a deep cut deep cut from like a star
wars role-playing game i believe in the
90s um i believe next episode we'll see
the fortress inquisitorius we'll see
vader uh obi-wan looks directly at
cameron says anakin smash cut to hayden
christensen in the back to tank
amazing music staying we got to credit
both john williams for coming up with
this new amazing ob1 sport and natalie
holt the loki composer who did all the
rest of the music for the series some
great tracks
throughout like i was i was captivated
by the musical storytelling um that's
we're going to talk about right now this
little moment between the two of them
it's like this is this they had a forced
link yes uh have they been sensing each
other have they been blocked by each
other who might have been blocking them
we'll talk about that in a second uh but
first we want to thank some people who
helped us make this episode and we'll be
right back a huge thanks to mint mobile
for sponsoring this episode of wikileaks
if you're tired of fine print contracts
and getting ripped off by big wireless
providers for your cell phone service
then maybe it's time for a switch mint
mobile offers premium wireless starting
at just 15 bucks a month they are the
first company to sell wireless service
online only they cut out the cost of
retail stores and pass those sweet
savings directly to you mint mobile
gives you the best rate whether you're
buying for one or for a family and at
mint families start at two lines all
plans come with unlimited talk and text
plus high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network we have
several members of the new rockstar
staff that use mint mobile editor wiley
got to use his own phone and keep his
same phone number along with all of his
existing contacts switch to mint mobile
and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month to get
your new wireless plan for just 15 bucks
a month and to get the plan shipped to
your door for free go to mintmobile.com
wookie that's mintmobile.com
w-o-o-k-i-e-e
cut your wireless build to 15 bucks a
month at bitmobile.comwookie
okay tommy our first question from this
episode uh
ha why haven't they been able to sense
each other was this the moment they
became aware of each other
um let's talk about that well i think we
see in the first episode obi-wan is
reaching out to people in his dreams
right like he calls out to qui-gon i
think obi-wan probably chalked it up to
sensing someone from the beyond the same
as he is seeking qui-gon perhaps he's
seeking redemption with anakin
as a forced ghost you know like maybe
he's like if i can reason with him
or if i can communicate with qui god
maybe the two of us can reach anakin and
like bring peace to at least his soul or
whatever the jedi you know believe in
that regard but i don't think he
considers the possibility of him being
alive and i think with vader the anger
his pure hatred and anger
blocks out his like understanding that
his children are alive at first and his
understanding that that obi-wan is you
know out there somewhere hiding i mean
obviously it probably assumes obi-wan is
alive right but like he knows obi-wan is
alive we know that from the chuck's soul
comics chucks charles whatever you want
to go by uh had uh we know when he
formed the the inquisitor he didn't form
it but when he took over the inquisitors
obi-wan's name showed up on there he
didn't fixate on it a lot but he knows
that obi wan is still alive hates him um
but like doesn't it seems like this
moment he was like i feel seen yeah you
know maybe he was just kind of like
the last little anakin in him was like
if he doesn't know i'm alive i'm not
gonna go after him yet and then now he's
like he knows i'm alive i gotta kill him
right
right uh it's like he woke him up from a
slumber like he's been so fixated on so
many other things vader rising to power
and taking control and you know being
number two in the empire and now all of
a sudden he's like personal vendetta
yeah you know it's like you know
business with pleasure yeah you know i
have to wonder if like you know some
something about the force may have kept
these two apart until now i mean i'm
just always going to say the force is
like the mystical force that keeps us
apart or keeps us together and i think
there may be a reason why these two were
kept apart until now uh i think the fact
that obi-wan didn't know is pretty
telling about his exile and how secluded
he's made and how much he gave up really
gave up on using the force and being in
tune and how alone he is like uh obi-wan
has said you know uh plenty of times how
he really believes in the strength but
strength of numbers among the jedi he's
part of a collective and you know that
it takes a village to uh to keep the
jedi orthodoxy he doesn't even use the
force in the privacy of his own home
right
in that cave he's not like closing
things and opening he's bitter he's like
rejected it he's uh he's using you know
a knife to cut the meat which is just
obviously he's not gonna karate chop it
with his hands i'm just saying like he
this is a man who's uh now salt of the
earth he's using his hands manually for
everything he doesn't use jedi mind
tricks when he could he doesn't use the
force at all
i think obviously not to out himself and
endanger luke but also as like a kind of
a
grudge i think he feels towards the
force and the jedi mindset certainly and
i think that seclusion that he's put
himself in
has extended to uh isolation from his
jedi friends who could call out him
that's why obi-wan does or that's why
qui-gon doesn't answer him i don't think
he's talked to uh yoda in years either
like the guy's been completely cut off
yeah who knows what yoda's doing yeah so
i think that's going to be his arc yeah
on this show is like by reconnecting
with anakin it's going to be almost a
reunion between obi-wan and the force
um and that's why it's why it's scary to
see the two reconnect it's also kind of
gets your heart racing because you're
happy for them that they're gonna be uh
connecting because there are so many
unresolved issues right that obviously
there's gonna be a jewel but i think
there were there needs to be words
exchanged between the two of them yeah
um they both
uh like and and vader's path forward uh
he needs to kind of figure out yeah he's
not yet the master yeah he's got more
lessons to learn from his own you think
we're gonna get hayden christensen's
voice we might under the mask oh see i'm
gonna ask i don't know i think that's
still james roll joe i think it's gotta
be james earl jones just because we
associate those two that image with that
with that voice right it's gonna feel
weird if you're hayden's voice yeah but
i want us the fact that we start with
him in the back of the tank start with
his face not with vader's mask right it
tells us a lot and i can't wait to see
more of that like that's what i want
from them and
um that's my ride
i feel like we should see some rebel uh
pilots on the back of that
um so i shot down a rebel transport
let's talk about some other questions so
we see the grand inquisitor gets stabbed
by riva huge power move by rebound and
very unexpected based on early trailers
for this right we were like grand
inquisitor he's obviously the man and
he's gonna live on because he's in
rebels which takes place after this so i
think we gotta just say there's no way
the grand inquisitor is dead yeah
because uh he's alive in rebels there's
plenty of ways that you can get bodily
uh
harm right paired up we just saw the mod
shop and the book of mormon
cat come on back thundercat is just
around the corner in the hour like
so i assume he's gonna get some
machinery in there i mean look if uh
something just fell from the tree and it
hurt um if uh if anakin skywalker can
get most of his body burnt off i think i
think the grand inquisitor
yeah yeah yeah i don't i mean she didn't
like twist she just no
no no i mean only harrison ford dies
that way spoiler for a movie that came
out six years ago um other questions
other questions we have okay so qui-gon
are we guaranteed to get acquired
we gotta be he's calling out to him yeah
it's not like he's like calling out to
like you know like something like just
like anakin or whatever like he says
qui-gon yoda told him that he's been
trying to be receiving you know whatever
forced vibrations from qui-gon yeah it's
got to happen come on baby give it to us
um are we gonna see or hear of any
rumors about the death star oh on this
show because we see alderaan right and i
think it's in the back of all of our
minds like oh it sucks to see this
beautiful place yeah uh it's all gonna
be gone yeah um you know we're gonna be
visiting the fortress inquisitors
there's really no reason for them to
have death star battle plans up on any
of their screens but like are we going
to see palpatine perhaps on the show
well how long ago did generous because
generously father is the architect of
the death star right uh yeah he's yeah
he's uh he's on the team so how long ago
i wonder how long prior to rogue one was
he supposed to be
working with the empire i wonder so
uh
rogue one is gonna be nine years from
now uh and that's the main events of
rogue one jenner so so yeah this is
around the time i think it makes sense
kidnapped uh what if we get a gallon or
so
chronic cameo i mean we just saw the
andor trailer today i feel like if
krennic or galen show yeah
but like i just want some uh maybe they
could just reference it like i mean i
think mcdarmod could do like a hollow
screen yeah
sure
and then uh and just kind of mention the
vader like
nothing can go wrong right now i'm
spending a lot of cash i'm very cash
stationed or asset rich right now
now's not a good time for me to invest
in your soda brand
i won't give you any capital money it's
a no for me
that's no from five sharks don thank you
for coming in have a good day
well done that's why i love co-hosting
this guy we're gonna leave it there what
an amazing first two episodes that was
an amazing first day of celebration i'm
so glad we get to do this
i know i'm going to be working through
the night on the breakdowns of episodes
i'm going to do a separate breakdown for
episode one a separate one for episode
two lots of easter eggs lots of little
references little things that like i
already started to notice i'm gonna be
working through the night to get these
done so the breakdown for episode one
coming out on saturday breakdown for
episode two coming out on sunday so i
appreciate your patience we love you and
we couldn't do it without you eric thank
you from all of us every all the fans
and me eric we really appreciate those
breakdowns they're the best and that's
why we keep coming back thank you guys
for watching thank you so much for
watching and again if you happen to
watch this and you're still in the anime
area we're going to be around all
weekend so come say hi to me danny's at
6 00 am
i'll be the one slamming coffee into my
face at a dangerous room moon's over my
tommy so uh
we appreciate you watching this again
check out our merch options on
uh newrockstarsmerch.com tommy at
tommybike to follow me at ea boss follow
new rockstars at new rockstar subscribe
to new rockstars for breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
and goodbye there
we go
wow we're good yeah we're good
[Music]
you